-Welcome, welcome, welcome,
welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show," everybody.
You're here.
You made it.
Thank you for watching.
What a beautiful fall day
we had today, huh?
Wasn't it gorgeous?
When I woke up,
there was a baby sparrow
nesting in my beard.
[ Laughter ]
Guys, I'm very excited about
this.
Jack Harlow is my co-host
tonight.
[ Cheers and applause ]
He's a stud.
Yeah, he also had the song of
the year, "First Class."
Everyone loves that.
Everyone loves that song.
Meanwhile, Spirit Airlines is
like, "Eh, it's not relatable."
[ Laughter ]
Spirit Airlines,
the subway in the sky.
[ Laughter ]
Hey, guys, let's get to
some news.
People are talking about this.
Yesterday President Biden went
down to Florida,
and during his visit, he was
caught on a hot microphone
talking to a local mayor.
Check this out. This is real.
[ Laughter ]
Biden basically has two modes --
sweet grandpa
and Tarantino movie.
[ Laughter ]
Biden sounds like
a hard-nosed P.I.
who wraps up cases by saying...
♪♪
Actually, Biden didn't stop
there.
He actually kept talking.
-Really?
-Yeah, we got exclusive footage.
Listen to this.
-Oh, my gosh.
Wow.
♪♪
-Some big news. Today, President
Biden pardoned all people
convicted of possessing
marijuana under federal law.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Signaling a major step towards
legalization.
I'm pretty sure Biden's approval
rating is about
to get high for the first time.
[ Laughter ]
-Whoa!
-Yeah, the President cancelled
student-loan debt.
And now he's pardoning people
for weed.
I think Biden's going to be able
to get into any frat
he wants right now.
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, I have a feeling
Trump is about to claim that all
his classified documents
were just rolling papers.
[ Laughter ]
Speaking of the former
president, yesterday Trump was
delivering remarks
when he brought up the FBI's
search of Mar-a-Lago.
And he's definitely looking
for the bright side here.
Take a look.
-Has anyone heard about
the document hopes
helicopters flying over
Mar-a-Lago?
Well, they've given us
about $5 billion worth
of free publicity, I will say.
People say,
"That's a nice house."
If it weren't so nice, they
probably wouldn't be doing it
because, you know,
it gets ratings.
When they look, they say,
"that's a beautiful place."
-Right now, Trump's watching
the Jeffrey Dahmer show like,
"Well, great publicity."
[ Laughter ]
"Really is.
A lot of people are watching
that show."
Listen to this.
I read that the Air Force just
announced a plan to reduce
their carbon footprint
and adapt to climate change.
Yeah, it's a major move.
In fact, the Air Force just
unveiled their new F-24 Prius.
Have you seen this?
[ Laughter ]
Guys, today marked the start of
New York Comic-Con.
Yeah.
[ Cheers ]
They're expecting
over 150,000 fans,
and a lot of them will be
in costume.
So we thought it would be
helpful to point out
the differences between
a New York Comic-Con Spider-Man
and a Times Square Spider-Man.
[ Laughter ]
For instance, Comic-Con
Spider-Man just paid 125 bucks
for a ticket to get in.
Times Square Spider-Man
just paid 125 bucks
of bail to get out.
[ Laughter ]
Next up, Comic-Con Spider-Man
wants to score with Mary Jane.
Times Square Spider-Man already
scored some Mary Jane.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Next up, Comic-Con Spider-Man
wears an official spandex suit
he bought online.
Times Square Spider-Man wears
a homemade suit that's part
Spanx, part Skims.
He calls them skanks.
[ Laughter and applause ]
And finally, Comic-Con
Spider-Man waits
for the bathroom in a long line.
Times Square Spider-Man goes to
the bathroom in his skanks.
[ Laughter ]
That's the difference.
Guys, get this, I heard that
the U.S. might start requiring
beer, wine, and spirits makers
to provide more information
on what's in their drinks.
These are strange times.
Weed is about to be legal,
but we need a full report
on what's in Bud Light Lime.
[ Laughter ]
Guys, finally, a house
in Michigan is going viral
after the owner synced up
his Halloween lights
to the tune of a song
from "Hocus Pocus 2."
Watch this.
-♪ One way or another,
we're gonna find ya ♪
♪ We're gonna get ya, get ya,
get ya, get ya, one way ♪
-Yeah, it seems annoying,
but it only plays on loop
for 18 hours a day.
[ Laughter ]
Guys, we have a great show.